[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
hey woman under ma I didn't get my bread
look good for what I didn't I didn't get
my what Garcon
so foul Oh mister you were looking at me
she didn't get our bread don't make me
come back damn cook having like a little
bit of trouble with Keefe lately Keith
you know what not that I don't like him
it's just that I don't want to be around
him yeah it's something about him that
makes me go you're kind of a slacker I
better get a cat at home I'm trying to
make a gynecologist appointment but the
website is down I won't you just call or
something I call them I don't want to do
that I'm sim Barisan hello hello this is
glozell I'm calling for Gaddy yes
something is wrong with her Bubba JJ huh
Virginia yes
what you hope that with him no way girl
here man I can't believe you did this
I've really enjoyed that movie I'm
telling you it was really good [ __ ]
the cops
yes who I meant who are these people
I just met him just now we're gonna go
hang out right Bella yeah parking
permits right yeah I also drive a car so
Jeremy did you tell them you've been to
our land oh yeah city wok
mr. braley lock yeah yeah city wok yeah
I'm also an Orlando file can you send an
airplane it'll go lamps right now
yes all right yeah okay bye how did you
say give her a chance something's wrong
with our she's a little shy